Welcome to Ruben select what an incredible run we've been on since the creation
of our own independent production company just two years ago.
Before I do anything else,
I got to give a huge thanks to all of you who have supported us from the
beginning as well as everyone who's joined along the way.
We've truly been on this adventure together and it's been an incredible ride.
You've enabled us to build a show in a production company that I couldn't be
prouder of.
You helped us build our home studio,
purchase top of the line equipment,
hire more great team members,
take the show on the road and so much more thanks to you.
We've not only survived youtube demonetization,
but I've also been able to say no to joining other networks are taking deals
that weren't the right fit.
Keeping our independence has allowed us to have the conversation that I believe
can help heal the divide in this country and in the world,
but these conversations that we foster here are only one part of the solution
and now it's time to kick it up a notch.
It's time to build real community.
Around the conversations we're having here on the Rubin report.
After emailing,
chatting with and meeting so many of you,
I'm completely convinced that the next steps in this adventure are to build a
home where you can not only listen to us but where others can listen to you as
well.
Social media can be great,
but it's really not the place for honest,
thoughtful dialogue,
so we're going to build something on Patriot and that can get you more involved
directly with us as well as each other.
All the while getting away from the outrage machine.
Think of it as the same space instead of a safe space.
Patrion will be our place to connect with you and most importantly for you to
connect with each other here you'll be able to share comments,
critiques,
and opinions with other people who are just as engaged in these ideas as you
are.
We'll build an ideologically diverse community of free thinkers from all around
the world,
all in one place.
That's where Reuben select comes in.
This'll be our home base for all things.
Ruben report powered by the very people who support the show you.
This is your direct link to me,
myself and my team will be in the comments and conversations ready to interact
with you as you interact with each other.
Plus,
if you join,
you'll get some cool perks such as behind the scenes footage,
bonus clips,
livestreams chats,
and much more as we grow,
our goal stays the same.
Having honest,
unfiltered longform discussions with people from every walk of life,
some of whom I agree with,
and some of whom I disagree with.
This thing has gone from a little youtube channel to something that's actually
moving the dial of the conversation as our influence grows.
So does our ability to really affect change,
and I want you to be as much part of that as I am,
as our community builds,
will be able to expand the team,
produce more content,
and introduce you to more people and ideas,
which will give you the tools to fight for what you believe in.
Level up in the conversation by joining Reuben.
Select now and let's continue this adventure together.
Okay.